North Carolina Governor Roy Cooper joins
us now from Raleigh good morning
governor a million people in your states
were asked to evacuate you said don't
bet your life on riding out the monster
we just heard from a man who we who is
staying put is there still time to leave
there is still time to leave the winds
may be down a bit but the one-two
intense punches that we are expecting or
still there
this storm surge can be deadly and then
the flooding that will come thereafter
with rain being measured in feet instead
of inches we know that this is an
extremely dangerous situation and we're
encouraging people not only your you may
be putting your life at risk you're also
putting first responders at risk who may
have to come and rescue you so yes there
is still time to get out and we're
asking people to leave we have shelters
open there over 90 shelters open now for
people on higher ground in safe
buildings we have almost 10,000 people
who've taken advantage of that and we
have hundreds of thousands of people who
are heading west and north we want them
to be safe and for those who aren't in
the evacuation zone in North Carolina
you're going to feel this thing it's
we're on the wrong side of the storm so
we're going to still get a lot of rain
and wind and we want people to hunker
down have their supplies and flashlights
and batteries the power companies expect
millions of people to be without power
for days so families need to be ready
and we're going to be there to help
Wow governor you hear that even if
you're not in the evacuation zone you
are gonna feel this it's gonna hurt your
home because of the lack of power and
food so be prepared let me ask you this
I know other states are they stepping in
to help this has been wonderful to get
help from states all over the country
I've been talking to fellow governors
they have been sending equipment swift
water rescue teams personnel to help us
I
just at one of our staging areas
yesterday and met with swift water
rescue teams from New Jersey and in Ohio
and New York and we are so grateful
North Carolina has helped other states
in the past now that help is coming back
to us the coordination is strong among
our local state and federal partners and
we're very grateful for the help people
stepping up coming from all over the
country we're all Americans and people
are saying we know you guys are about to
get a hit
so we're there to help you and we're
grateful for that it is one of the
things about these stories everybody
leans in to try and help governor Cooper
we are thinking of you and the residents
of your state thank you so much we're
gonna get through this thank you